Ahmed Alito has been living in this camp
for displaced people in the northern
Syrian city of azaz for six years like
many others here he was forced from his
home in Tel rifat less than 20
kilometers South when the white pgc's
control over the city from the
opposition
will the Turkish government saying it
intends to launch a ground offensive
against the Syrian Kurdish group Ahmed
hopes he'll soon be able to return home
safely
life is difficult here on farmlands we
live in tents we soak in the winter and
burn in the summer we are ready to
reclaim our stolen lands and homes the
lands where we spent our childhood
ahmed's mother wants to return to tell
rifat it's a possible Target for a
Turkish military operation after Ankara
blamed the ypg for a bomb attack in
Istanbul earlier this month she says
leaving was not her choice
at home you live like a king but here
it's tense it's not a life anymore
even if our houses are destroyed we can
still build tents over the rubble just
let us get back
trucia says the ypg is the Syrian branch
of the Kurdistan Workers Party or pkk
and it doesn't want what it considers
threats along its borders with Iraq and
Syria
but the ypg is also supported by the
United States which focuses on the
Kurdish group's opposition to isil any
Turkish incursion into Northern Syria
risks making relations between the two
NATO allies more difficult than they
already are the commander of the Syrian
Democratic forces Muslim abdisas a
Turkish offensive could also Target
membage and einel arap and has
threatened to reply with attacks along
turkey's borders
thousands of syrians living across the
border are facing a difficult Choice the
years-long war have forced them from
their homes in other parts of Syria some
say they support the Turkish military
operation hoping it will bring peace and
stability but others say they don't have
anywhere else to go because turkey is
adamant that it won't take in any more
refugees
Southeastern turkey